when Elon Musk purchased Twitter for 44
billion dollars he inherited a company
that had not turned a profit for eight
of the past 10 years they were having
trouble attracting new users they're
having trouble uh increasing the revenue
it's tough to determine the state of
Twitter's Financial Health now that it's
a private company but analysts have been
able to piece together an assessment
from the company's last regulatory
filings and musk's public statements
s p data showed that Twitter had less
than 600 million dollars in net debt
before the Takeover talks now post
acquisition they have 13 billion dollars
in debt and that's a major burden on
their shoulders the company last year
generated just over 630 million dollars
in operating cash flow while this new
debt could potentially swell its
interest payments to more than one
billion dollars a year that's a lot of
money that they have to pay down with
cash and where are they going to find
that cash just one week after taking
over the company musk said in tweets
that Twitter had suffered a massive drop
in revenue and was losing over four
million dollars a day the journal has
reported that a number of big
advertisers have paused their spending
on the platform nearly 90 percent of
Twitter's Revenue last year came from
advertising analysts have pointed to
this you know being a significant
decline in Revenue as major companies
leave over concerns over what's the the
future of the business model what's the
vision under musk to make ends meet musk
has moved quickly to slash costs
including cutting the company's staff by
half filings showed Twitter had 5 500
full-time employees at the end of 2020
and 7 500 a year later based on the
company's most recently disclosed median
pay figure the layoffs of about 3 700
people could save Twitter roughly 860
million dollars a year this represents
about 15 percent of Twitter's 5.57
billion dollars in costs and expenses
last year analysts have noted that this
could do more harm than good because
some of the company's most critical
engineers and developers and marketers
are heading out the door the billionaire
owner has also been trying to add
subscription Revenue with the Twitter
blue service which gives users a blue
verified check mark if they pay 7.99 a
month it's unclear whether there's
enough demand for that but subscription
revenue is potentially a new outlet a
new opportunity to make up for the
revenue that's been lost amid the recent
Advertiser accidents in an all hands
meeting with Twitter staff on November
10th musk warned that bankruptcy is a
possibility for the company analysts and
academics said even if these Financial
challenges continue to mount there could
be other options he could raise Equity
he could buy back debt from lenders
potentially at a very deep discount in
the event that the company does go into
bankruptcy this is not a musk's
preferred option he put 27 billion
dollars of his own money in the business
and that likely means that those funds
will be entirely wiped out the remains
to be seen what direction he'll take